where are you implanting this into it
into another device what are you
implanting this so it's actually going
into your ear
in your ear how you're pushing it in so
i could direct your attention to the
first slide
here's the surgery location oh that's a
bad first line
imagine somebody walks in the first
slide of their pitch deck is implant
injection coordinates
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar you know the thing i'm
your host coffee zilla and yes we
haven't made many uploads this week
which means i'm going back to basics i
was
going back to the reactions the thing
that built this channel and i think i
found the perfect one to bring back the
reactions with
shark tank ladies and gentlemen season
one episode one the man the myth the guy
who started it all i don't know if you
guys have seen season one episode one of
shark tank you won't see any other
youtubers doing this it's the ionic ear
now already you can kind of tell the
time period of shark tank from where
this is from because of the uh potato
camera quality this is before they all
became rich off of cameo like kevin
o'leary so let's watch a little together
huh
next up is darren johnson who hopes his
innovative new product will send the
sharks into a frenzy
the music's tight what the [ __ ]
wait a second you you they they tricked
us they just went from a regular shot of
kevin o'leary to what is this
my name is darren johnson and i'm here
today to explain the ionic year
investment opportunity how much money
are you looking for i'm looking for a
million dollars for a 15 percent
ownership stake and oh yeah
you're never gonna get it dude i've seen
the shark tank episodes first of all
it's kind it's not even about how good
your idea is they always want like
80 of your company if they're gonna give
you over like a hundred thousand dollars
if you've seen a couple episodes of
shark tank you know that's true anytime
you say fifteen percent they go nah i'll
take um eighty percent of your company
and every dollar you've made uh since
then what we have developed is a
implantable bluetooth technology if you
are one of the 40 percent of the users
of bluetooth technology that currently
own it you know that just the natural
rhythm
blocking many times and perspiration the
technology will fall off your ear if you
answer the call too quickly many times
the bluetooth device will become
dislodged that's why we decided to screw
it directly into your ear
hey this guy might actually be onto
something i want to say that from the
get-go this is 2015. he might be the
visionary we all needed because this
indeed was a problem i don't know if the
answer was boring a hole in your ear
like it sounds like he's thinking but uh
it's interesting i'm sorry where are you
implanting this into a into another
device what are you implanting this is
actually
[Music]
in your ear how you're pushing it in so
i could direct your attention to the
first slide this is just underneath the
ear the surgery location this is this is
surgery you would be under anesthesia oh
my god
[Music]
you guys are so close-minded please let
him finish okay
you're about to create a super villain
laughing this guy off state he's going
to go oh yeah you think that's funny two
years later everyone's mind controlled
by some ionic ear device at the base of
the device is a battery within its
center or bluetooth electronics and at
its tip a microphone a speaker and an ac
charging port stop right there
back
to surgery 101.
darren we're gonna we're gonna operate
on people yes we are we're gonna stick
something
so casual dude this guy first of all i
don't believe he's a doctor don't
believe he's like yes human test
subjects trial one
yes we are darren we're gonna we're
gonna operate on people yes we are we're
gonna stick something in
near their brain
we may not puncture their
you know what is pretty disturbing
and it freaks me out i'm already out
how do i charge it every night so we
have you what this is an apple watch you
got to plug your ear in the ac charging
port
can you stick that needle in your head
every night to charge it
okay i was with you till then darren i'm
out i don't know about you guys what do
you think how many of you are still in
do a quick poll i'd say probably 50 of
you are still in he just inserted a
thumbtack into the guy's ear even the
model doesn't look pleased the satellite
base station enters your ear canal
needle in your head every night to
charge it yes you would okay you don't
think oh my god
are you
seriously
like
seriously i need like a small q-tip
cylinder you know what half the problem
is like the first slide in implant
injection coordinates you'd never say
that if you're actually going to make an
idea that works you'd say something like
device location injection implant
coordinates all things that sound
horrible this guy's like q-tip bass
station this guy's like talking about
like q-tips docking into your skull this
is not exactly a friendly thing now if
say you're a billionaire and you just
say like oh yeah in order to interface
with ai we need to stick something in
your ear then everyone loves you and
fawns over you but if you're this guy
you just don't have the it's he's not
pitching it right what happens if you
missed that so that you can't miss it
you can't miss
sure there's going to be safety features
built into it darren i need to be clear
on this before i write you off as a nut
job which i'm trying not to do
i have to understand
a team of doctors implanted in your neck
below your ear sure and then you stick
something in your ear in the evening
something what convinces you something
that's the size of a q-tip or s'more
something to charge it everywhere you
have a cylinder that delivers ac charge
at a very trickle lower knife
yeah yes yes we will plug you up to your
house circuitry uh don't worry we'll
have a breaker installed we can't miss
this guy is the best first guest ever i
can see now why the episode was a huge
success that the show is a huge success
i don't know if you guys have seen this
before i had never seen this episode
how do i do an upgrade i go back and get
another operation you would have to go
in and receive an additional operation
do you see a problem with that sure
there there's certainly
i have a problem with that i am out this
is the weirdest damn thing i ever heard
now wait wait i feel like they're not
actually addressing the true problem
with this idea so far you have to
understand that he's asking people to
com have two surgeries dock up to a base
station why all because what's the
actual probably something the headphones
fall out of your ear sometimes
that's the problem
it's just not too big of a problem
darren i don't know uh what what the
issue is here
the first time that you heard of breast
implants
what did you think i love it right
okay
but as a woman
hey
okay they're not a plan to get into your
johnson okay this is not an enlargement
idea i don't know what this guy's
thinking they're two completely
different things
what do you want to do or would it take
market acceptance and a lot of testing
and a lot of medical treatment before
except
us in the room about this yes i have and
you're still walking around free i see
sure don't call me i'll call you i'm out
okay darren here is here's insanity
here's genius
you're somewhere
nevertheless i'm out wow that was
actually pretty nice i would have just i
thought he was going to go here's the
saturday here's genius this is you off
somewhere off screen because you're
fired and you're out
thank you
[Music]
well that's it did he actually go on to
create create it is is that a real
company the ionic gear appears to have
never taken off as the cover you don't
say the company has no website there is
no record of the surgery ever taking
place uh so it's likely the idea failed
and darren gave up on it many of the
sharks mentioned it as the craziest idea
on the tank including barbara on the
100th episode wow so dara basically
knocked it out of the park from day one
listen i gotta say uh he's got my vote
not as a good idea or an investable idea
by the way i mean as the craziest idea
ever as on shark tank well that about
does it for this episode anyway i hope
you enjoyed uh have a lovely day i'll
see you in the next one
[Music]
what a shame what a shame you're a fraud
are you the same as so you're saying no
you're not